i have this habit of every single
morning i stand in front of the mirror
and i take a moment and i raise my hand
and i give my reflection a high five and
there is so much science behind this so
instead of seeing yourself and having
this moment in the mirror you know what
the average person does first of all we
beat ourselves down so i would look in
the mirror for 40 some years and be like
oh my god my freaking jowls look like
saddlebags on a goddamn horse going in
the grand canyon like i start bringing
myself down and when you start going
down that road with your reflection then
your thoughts go to i didn't get to that
email i forgot to text lisa back oh my
gosh the dog still needs to be walked
you're now checking out and that moment
in the mirror every morning could be a
profound moment where you lift yourself
up and you check back in with your
intention so the first piece of research
and this is recent from harvard business
school is that a simple moment in the
morning where you set an intention about
who you're going to be today impacts
productivity how you show up as a leader
it impacts your confidence it impacts
your mood all day long just that simple
moment of setting an intention so that's
research number one instead of standing
in front of the sink in your bathroom
and criticizing your appearance or
mindlessly going on autopilot check back
in and let's teach you to make it a
habit to lift yourself back need
motivation you better watch a top 10
with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best mel robbins and my take on
her top 10 rules of success
enjoy
[Music]
second piece of research and this comes
from a whole field of study called
neurobics neurobics is like aerobics for
your mind i didn't make this up
this is literally you can speed up the
development of new neural pathways by
marrying physical activity
with a change in thought
and so traditionally i know you've
covered this on your show if you for
example were to brush your teeth i'm a
right-hander if you were to brush it
with your other hand and think
a new thought
the fact that your brain is focusing on
brushing with your non-dominant hand
activates more focus on the new thought
it accelerates the learning so you take
neurobics a physical activity with a
different thought and let me let's talk
about a high five for example
what does a high five mean to you
that somebody did something awesome or i
did something awesome correct and if you
think about the times in your life when
you've gotten a high five
it's because somebody's like tom you're
amazing tom get your attitude out of the
can you got this tom you're gonna make
this shot tom we can still win i believe
in you keep going
you have a lifetime
positive association with giving other
people high fives stored right here in
your subconscious mind when you raise
your hand to your own reflection it is
impossible for you to think god i look
fat
why am i an [ __ ] i really screwed up
my life you can't do it because your
lifetime association with this motion is
all i believe in you i got you i see you
i celebrate you and so you in the moment
of doing it override decades of negative
self-talk it's incredible
now have you ever gotten a high five
where somebody misses the hand or it's
sort of like it sucks right yeah what do
you do when that happens i redo it
correct
that's because a high five requires you
to be present and there is an intention
behind it
so you can't raise your hand to your own
reflection without now grounding
yourself in the moment rule number two
find your power i don't believe in toxic
positivity i don't believe that you just
like put a positive spin on things and
things will disappear and be fine
that's not how the world works there are
very real challenges that you may be
facing you may be facing abuse violence
you may be up against structural and
systematic racism and bias and
discrimination you may be facing extreme
poverty you may be facing all kinds of
very real and traumatic things in your
life
simply putting a positive spin on things
will not change those very real
obstacles what it changes is you
when you change how you look at things
it changes your ability to deal with the
things in your life it changes your
ability to face hard things and it gives
you the courage and the confidence and
the resilience and the stamina to chip
away at these large obstacles or these
past experiences that created trauma or
negative self-talk it's going to give
you the ability to take the action that
you need and so when you hear me talk
about mindset i want you to understand
this doesn't make things disappear it
actually empowers you to be your
greatest self to face the stuff that's
very difficult you know because
confidence
courage resilience these are all things
that are inside you and you don't build
this stuff
in the high moments you build your
confidence and your courage and your
resilience in the low moments it's like
steel it's forged in the fire of your
life and so even in those moments where
you feel like life is punching you in
the face and you just want to give up
and you have that like i can't handle
this anymore and why does this keep
happening to me i am telling you do not
give up because you are building your
inner strength every step of the way
through these experiences that you're
facing in your life i'm not saying it's
fair i'm not saying you deserve it i'm
saying you have the power within you to
face whatever you're dealing with to
find your strength and to actually
change yourself and the situation and
the trajectory that you're on for the
better rule number three look forward
there is no fast track to transformation
you have to work on it in little ways
every day you can't buy self-esteem or
self-love you must build it you must
stand face to face with the part of you
that you hate
you must forgive yourself for the hurt
that you've caused especially the hurt
you've caused yourself
and then you got to do the work to
become a better you
it's the only way to create the
self-respect and build the self-esteem
that you want you can change there are
do-overs in life because you get one
every single morning when you wake up
look in the mirror and decide who you're
going to be today you can choose you can
change no you can't go back in time but
you can have your own back as you use
the time that you have now to take
control and create a new chapter that
makes you proud of who you are
the hardest part of all this is flipping
your focus
from what you hate and are trying to fix
toward what you want to create
remember the windshield in a car is
bigger than the rear view mirror for
good reason you're not supposed to go
backwards you're supposed to drive your
life forward and that means you must
start looking ahead
yeah you screwed up me too the worst
things that you've done witnessed or
survived they are your most powerful
teachers so stop making yourself wrong
about what happened and unpack it
understand it
face yourself in the mirror and learn
the lessons that are woven into every
mistake
every regret you ever have and every
painful thing you've ever experienced
here's the profound insight i gained
that i want you to hear you aren't
broken
you're just blocked
forgive yourself for all the things you
did while you were just trying to
survive rule number four cheer for
yourself the dallas uber driver oh so as
somebody who has gotten into
countless ubers and some small
percentage of them know who i am and
then of course they start asking
questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
um
yeah the uber driver in dallas that's in
this book um
i get choked up when i think about him
an aha moment
i get choked up
because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day
you've got millions and millions of
people that
are inspired by empowered by impacted by
your content there are people out there
that
use your work as a lifeline
and it is humbling and what i am
really present to
in the work that i'm putting out in the
stuff that i'm sharing whether it's my
failures or the things that i'm using
that are helping me and my own struggles
is just
how much people are holding themselves
back
and how
much pain people feel
because most folks know
what they dream about
and what they want
and yet
they're spending all of their time and
energy arguing against
what they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
i hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment
but it's not going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going i got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go
i don't know if i'm worth that i don't
know if right now is the right time to
do this i don't think i'm good enough i
failed so many times i can't go through
that door
and that's the problem i want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life
that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you
and you are actively arguing against it
you're bringing yourself down you're
beating yourself out like people will
cheer for you and me they won't cheer
for themselves
i'm the same way
and so this uber driver
the story that you're talking about i
get into the car
and
we start driving and i'm on the phone as
we're driving and i'm having a
conversation with somebody about this
daytime talk show that i launched which
was a dream with sony pictures
television and then uh was promptly
fired after season one it was a huge
failure because we didn't make it to
season two
huge failure in real world terms
massive success when it comes to the
timeline of my life
and so i'm talking to this person about
the talk show i hang up the phone and
this uber driver comes alive he's like
oh my gosh i can't believe you're in my
cab
and i'm like why and he says because i i
want to talk to you about something i
think you can help me and i'm like great
how can i help you and he says
i have a dream of being a oscar-winning
uh actor and creating opportunities for
other black and latino men to do the
same in acting and i'm like freaking
fantastic what the [ __ ] are you doing in
dallas
right yeah the guy's 25 and so
i i go you know the game is in new york
and la i mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in dallas
but why are you not in la why are you
not in new york and he's like you're
right you're right you're right i need
to move to la like why not
and he says i have seven hundred dollars
in my bank account and i'm like that's
freaking fantastic you have seven
hundred dollars in a car
dude drop me off and get driving what
are you waiting for and so we have this
whole conversation and i write about it
in this book
where
i am actively arguing for his dream and
he is actively arguing against his dream
and
what is so sad
is throughout this conversation tom he's
like you're right 700 could get me there
you're right i am only 25. you're right
if i keep thinking and thinking and
thinking and thinking about what i want
to be doing i'm not only going to drive
in circles my whole life is going to
spin in circles as i think about what i
want and i don't do [ __ ] about it
and then you are going to find yourself
not at 25 but at 45 or 65 and you're
going to be so filled with regret that
you never put a put a bet on yourself
and so
this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
california and me giving him a bunch of
tools that i talk about in this book
and the point of the story is does he
move or not i don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us
we do not know how to do it for
ourselves
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five listen and validate
there are four techniques that i use
whenever i'm gonna have a difficult
conversation that help me
stay focused on what i need to talk
about instead of getting hijacked by my
emotions number one i always start the
conversation by acknowledging
my responsibility in the mess that we
have to talk about whether it's the fact
that i've avoided dealing with this
sooner or whether there's something that
i've done that's contributed to the
situation i acknowledge it right up
front and one of the reasons why that's
so important is because by accepting
some responsibility you're diffusing the
other person's emotion you're also
honoring them a little bit and it sets a
much more level playing field for when
you get into the difficult things that
you need to talk about it's also going
to put the person that you're speaking
to
a little at ease so they're going to be
able to listen number two you want to
have a goal
never go into a difficult conversation
without an outcome defined before you go
into it the reason why the outcome is so
important is because this conversation
is going to be a roller coaster the
person that you're talking to might get
upset you yourself might feel emotional
at some point whether you're angry or
you're triggered or you get sad and so
when you ride the roller coaster of
emotion the thing that is going to
stabilize your thoughts is the outcome
that you're causing you're having this
conversation because you're committed to
making the relationship better you're
having this conversation because this
isn't working and so we need to end it
powerfully you're having this
conversation because you want to give
somebody some feedback that's not so fun
to tell them but you're giving it to
them because you're committed to their
success okay so that goal you feel
yourself getting emotional you come back
to it you come back to it you come back
to it
third thing you're going to do a lot in
this conversation you're going to listen
and you're going to validate
so you're going to say what you need to
say and then the other person's going to
react
and instead of arguing or debating i
want you to listen and i want you to
validate what the person is saying may
sound counterintuitive but honestly one
of the most powerful things you can do
in any conversation whether you're
fighting with your kids over curfew or
you're arguing with somebody at work
over workloads whatever it may be is
here where the person's at
the moment you say wow
that must be really tough
what you're dealing with or
oh i totally get why you now were
avoiding me
if i felt the way that you felt i'd
probably do the same thing
the second you validate somebody they
immediately stop defending themselves
it's unbelievable actually
unbelievable you've got to try it
validate validate validate it is the
most powerful thing and then once of
course they feel validated that you've
heard them now they can listen
and that's when you come back to the
final thing which is you're going to
restate always the outcome
keep coming back to it keep coming back
to it
and yeah it's not going to be fun
it's not going to be easy
you're going to have all kinds of
emotions come up because you've been
avoiding this conversation
but i'm telling you right now
if you find the confidence and the
courage to go and to start this thing
knowledge your responsibility have an
outcome in mind validate the other
person validate validate validate and
keep talking till you hit that outcome
you're going to be really really amazed
at how much easier these things become
and if you want to make it even easier
on yourself rehearse it with another
friend first somebody that's not
involved in the situation because again
difficult conversations comes down to
one important thing
the ability for you to separate your
emotion about doing it from the things
you actually need to talk about and the
outcome that you want to cause rule
number six pursue your dreams let's
start with a metaphor
i want you to think about your life like
a book
a book is divided into chapters
some chapters are boring and a grind to
get through and others are exciting and
you hope they never end and right now
you're in a chapter
[Music]
maybe this chapter of your life is a
grind it's overwhelming and unsatisfying
and you feel stuck reading it over and
over again
maybe you want to start a new chapter
but you don't know what the next chapter
is about and so you keep re-reading the
one you're currently in
here's the greatest thing about life
you don't have to know where this next
chapter is going
you just have to start writing it
i want you to envision a blank page
what do you want to write
what do you see for yourself
i don't want you to try to figure out
what job or business you should write on
that page
what belongs on that page are the dreams
that you have for yourself and your life
and all that's required to start writing
is to start saying yes instead of
telling yourself no
yes you should start that podcast
yes you should go back to school
yes you should try to launch that
business
whatever it is that you've been doing
whether you're three years out of
college and it's a job you can't stand
from a major you hate or it's a 20-year
career that you're just burnt out on
or maybe you stepped away from the
workforce to raise your kids or perhaps
like so many people right now you've
been laid off
this is the moment to write your next
chapter
you're not too late
[Music]
you're right on time
all you need is a blank page
and a pen rule number seven build
discipline
one of the things that i think you
should always come back to
first is take a look at how you set your
day up because how you set it up is how
it ends up how do i set my day up
so that i'm practicing what i call
simple discipline simple discipline is
nothing more than making and keeping
simple promises to yourself repeating it
every day the way that you start to
change the big things is you change the
small things make tiny teeny teeny
promises to yourself and then keep them
so how do you build simple discipline
here are some core skills that i do
every morning that have helped me number
one
i do not sleep with the phone
number two when the alarm goes off on my
phone it's not near me so i have to get
my ass out of bed i get up i make my bed
i get moving
i get my exercise clothes on i move my
body i then journal i take 10 minutes to
myself to plan my day when i do that my
day is incredible i believe that how you
start your day dictates how the day goes
you should not just adopt somebody
else's morning routine and expect it to
work for you you need to customize this
you are unique i think about how do you
come alive for yourself in the morning
what are the five senses what's the
first thing that you see
when you wake up for me it's a painting
that i manifested out of thin air it
reminds me that what you put your mind
to and what you work toward
it will become a reality i always light
incense because it makes my senses and
my nose come alive i'm super mindful
over what i taste first thing in the
morning my grandma always had vinegar in
the morning with honey and hot water i
picked the one thing that matters to me
today rule number eight face the
challenges one of the biggest objections
that people had to
standing in front of the mirror take a
moment look at yourself and then raise
your hand
as people said over and over and over
again
i haven't done anything
worthy
of high fiving
high fiving feels like a celebration
i don't have the number on the scale
that i want
i don't like my bank account i don't
enjoy what i do for a living i've made a
load of mistakes
i'm struggling with trauma
i don't have anything to celebrate
and what i realized is
people are making a fundamental mistake
you are withholding the very support
empowerment and celebration that you
need to change and to do the hard work
and to face the things that you're
scared of
and that's why
you're not changing rule number nine be
willing to try i think that confidence
is the willingness to try see i anchor
confidence in action
because
i don't believe
that belief in self
is the thing that makes people
act confidently
i believe that when you
are willing to try even though you doubt
yourself
that
the act of trying
and seeing yourself move through your
doubts and your fears and your
procrastination and your perfectionism
the act of moving through it is what
starts to build belief in self
so i define confidence as the
willingness to try
arrogance is believing you're better
than anybody else
and i think confidence is this quiet
knowing that you can rely on yourself
even the most confident people so people
that rely on themselves and people that
are willing to try and take risks
[Music]
hit periods where they really doubt
themselves and they don't feel confident
in their decision making and their
actions and so i think it's a skill that
comes and goes and
that you'll always be working on it
because the whole point about life is to
grow and as you grow you're going to
face new challenges and whenever you
face a new challenge it's going to
you know bring up fears and doubt and
that's why you're going to need to work
on the skill of confidence which is the
willingness to try that's where it
begins and rule number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
stick with the facts i am making cabbage
faro soup it sounds disgusting it is
delicious it is from my absolute
favorite um
cookbook six seasons by joshua mcfadden
um but that's not why i made this video
i made this video because i want to
share a recipe for
relieving pain tension frustration and
hurt in your life
every day all kinds of stuff happens to
you right some good some bad some
frustrating some some things that are
amazing
and
for everything that happens to you there
are three versions
of what happens there's your version and
the story that you tell yourself about
what happened
there's a second version which is the
version that the other person that's
involved in the story
tells themselves about what happened
and then there's the truth
and the truth is just the facts
no story no explanation it's just what's
so so i'm gonna give you a quick example
so i'm sitting here cooking
and
um i've got a lot i got to clean up i
got stuff all over the counter i've been
working on some architectural plans over
there i got to clean that up so i'm
starting to clean up and i come over
here to the sink
and i notice
someone that i loves egg dish is right
there
now
i'm not going to out them i'm also going
to not out the fact that part of the uh
breakfast that they were creating for
themselves which involved
sweet potato
and making some eggs is still out and
that said person is nowhere to be found
so let's talk about the three versions
of this story
version number one is my version
which goes a little something like why
does my family
believe
that i
am the maid this is being done to me how
rude they expect me to do this
like on and on and on you can see that
story about the fact
that there is an egg dish here
and there are knives that need to be
cleaned that story i'm telling myself
gets me really jacked up and angry and
frustrated and feeling used and annoyed
and of course when your mood switches
it can hijack your whole day
now
version number two
would probably be
holy cow i'm coming back later of course
you don't need to clean it up
i'm just in an online
uh jam session
working on a song i have to record
for my class
and in fact
if we're quiet
[Music]
now here's the cool part
you don't have to tell yourself a story
you can just see something and not make
it mean anything
at all and in fact here she comes
she's done doing her thing and she's
coming back in to clean up i torture
myself and you torture yourself for no
good reason
so
check your story
stick with the facts and i think you'll
find that life is a lot
less stressful and frustrating
anyone that's going through some really
confronting stuff in their personal life
that's me right now don't really
feel ready to discuss any of the details
but it is a very challenging moment
right now for me
and the waves of emotion
all of them are coming and going
right now in my life
and
i want to share something that i am
finding helpful
as i move through this
really
[Music]
tough moment in time
i remind myself that these feelings are
temporary number one
and that helps me
find strength and knowing that i'm gonna
learn something in this moment i'm gonna
ride through this pain
and i'm gonna come out stronger and i
won't always feel like that like i do
right now
the second thing is um
i try not to attach myself to the waves
that are coming of
sadness and anger and fear and
frustration and
just all of it and uh
by that i mean i let the wave
of emotion come into my body
i try not to hold on to it grip it
attach it i feel what i need to feel
and i breathe it out
that's number two
and number three a lot of journaling
a lot of journaling just
pouring out everything i'm feeling as a
way to excavate it responsibly anyway i
wanted to make this video because i know
you're probably going through something
i know you're probably experiencing
waves of emotion frustration sadness
anger joy whatever it may be you're
human
this is a human experience to feel
emotional waves and so remind yourself
whether it's a high or a low it's
temporary
you can get through this
breathe through the wave don't attach
yourself to it and let it knock you over
and
three just dump everything you're
feeling out into a journal instead of at
other people and that will help you
process the emotions you need to process
because you don't want to shove them
down
it will help you get clear about where
you want to go
next
and what you're meant to learn in this
moment and it will help you move through
it with grace with strength with
resilience so in the ted talk i cited
this this statistic that i had read uh
years ago and that is that a scientist
had calculated the odds of you and me
being born and when you think about just
even the
sexual act of your parents in a lifetime
relationship the number of times they
would actually be intimate the amount of
sperm that go the the odds of one egg
and one sperm and then you throw in then
you throw in the dna
and the uniqueness of your dna structure
some scientists calculated all of those
odds and figured out that the odds of
you being you who you are
born the day that you were born to the
parents that you have with the dna
structure that you have given all the
other variables that could have changed
something
the odds are one in 400 trillion that
you are you and so what that means to me
is that you're meant to be here that
there is a reason why you were born and
the journey of your life is to figure it
out and i think it's actually simple
i think that life is very simple and we
complicate it because we have brains
that can tell stories and
we have um bodies that can sense danger
and so
we over complicate things and the the
purpose of your life is to listen to
your heart and soul
and to follow it and to
express the highest version of you not
the self-doubt not the anxiety not the
fears not the pettiness not the
frustrations but to actually have the
courage to be
fully expressed
as as like
i it sounds stupid but you know as the
as a great human being to have the
courage to be kind to have the courage
to be patient to have the courage to
cheer for other people and have the
courage to tune into that wisdom that's
inside of you and lean into it follow
the things that pique your curiosity do
more of the that actually expands your
heart and expands the amount of energy
in your body and slowly but surely if
you align all your decisions and the
things that you spend time on and the
people that you spend time on with the
things that naturally energize you your
whole life will experience a shift i've
always wanted a six-pack and i don't
have it
and i don't know and i've never had it
and
when i i finally stopped complaining
about it when i got honest
about what it was going to require
oh i'm dead serious
dead serious about this at my you know
at 49
with my affinity for alcohol
and my love of carbs and my taste for
exercise
i have a small problem on my hands if i
want a six-pack so if you were to go
forward right and think okay well if a
year from now i had a six-pack
what would what would that actually what
would my day-to-day life look like
and you can get very clear that you're
not committed to that
and then you can stop beating yourself
up for the you never intend on doing
what i realized is i can spend four
minutes a day in a hotel room or in my
bedroom doing planks and my arms look
great and everybody else will think the
rest of my body's in shape
and we're good
we're good
yes
it looks like a charm so you might want
to get honest with yourself like instead
of doing this i really don't want to be
a millionaire
do you really
because you can make it happen you
actually can look at all the idiots that
are making money you can make money
but you're gonna have to roll the clock
forward just a year and say okay if i'm
able to
put
a thousand dollars a month against my
debt i'm able to make x amount of
dollars a month i'm able to put x amount
of dollars in savings what do i need to
be doing a year from now to make that
happen and what are those habits that
are there a year from now that i don't
have right now
and then roll yourself back to this
moment just like i explained with
exercise do i actually not want to have
a manhattan tonight nope
did i want to go to the gym today nope
did i would am i am i willing to not eat
what i ate for nope
am i willing i did my four minutes my
arms are looking really good
but so bring it back and then you will
have the formula for pivoting at any
moment you time travel forward a year
you investigate the patterns that you
have that are giving you the result that
you want and then you back your ass up
to right here right now and you decide
am i willing to do this now if i'm
willing then 54321 through all the
excuses that are going to be there when
you're trying to override your operating
system that's how you do it or you have
the reality check like i had which is oh
i just like to
i don't intend on changing so why don't
we get this off the plate and let's
focus on the things that i am actually
committed to where do you find that
that shift of like i need to get off of
this because we'll be i'll be spending
time with like my fiance or with my
family i it popped into my head oh my
gosh i need to text this person i forgot
i needed to call and get this order
fixed
how do you
find
that shift to just say you know what i'm
spending time with my family and i'll do
it tomorrow but not like in a
procrastinating it's an excellent
question i think if you're present
to
whether or not you're kind of in the
zone of time where it's cool to be fluid
you're kind of with the family you're
also sort of present on your phone
that's cool if you've decided that
because my kids are starting to complain
or my fiance's starting to complain that
i'm always like this then
you got honor that if you're gonna say
i'm putting down the phone between seven
and nine o'clock tonight and i'm
actually just going to be present with
you you've got to honor it so what i
will do is i'll just jot a note to
myself so instead of picking up the
phone i'll just jot a note down and
you've had the experience right where
you gotta like be in a meeting at the
school or you have to catch a plane or
you've got a doctor's appointment and
have you ever noticed that when you've
got an anchor like that your whole day
condenses and you're more productive
because you've got this deadline and
that's called parkinson's law so
parkinson's law it's a research-backed
fact that when
you have work to do it will expand to
the amount of time that you have to do
it
so if you have 20 minutes to make a call
how long will it take you
if you have two weeks to make it how
long will it take you
correct so if you s every day
no phone in your room you set that one
priority that matters to you if you got
time to kind of inch it forward just a
little bit great you've already made
progress you're done for the day then
you look at your phone you also set a
quitting time right then and there the
majority of days you'll honor it and
that quitting time means for me it means
i'm not on my phone and everybody that
works for me if knows if there's an
emergency or if we have to do something
they'll call me so that that helps a lot
if you had to pick
one word
that was you
one word that represented your essence
and so let me explain what i mean by
essence have you ever been around a dog
that gets wet and they shake
and then their gets all over you
that to me is the definition of essence
so you walk into a room
what is it
that
shakes off onto other people what's the
word right here
excited anyone else
determined
kind
energy back in the back just shout out
thoughtful
love
sexy
awesome so it was interesting because
the word that fell out because i
immediately thought i wonder if mine is
confidence and then i thought well wait
a minute actually no
it's try
all i want you to ever do is try that's
it
i just want you to try in those moments
where you hear yourself i want you to
try in those moments where you know that
it's time to speak up i want you to try
that's all that i ever ask of you
because if you simply do that and i say
simply as if it's so easy right
you will literally unlock the potential
of your life here's another massive
insight so i always think about
businesses levels right and i also
realized that as the media landscape or
the um
the particular vertical or industry that
you're building a business in is
changing that is a constant and it's
something that you can't control right
you just cannot control the things that
are happening in the world around us but
you can
always control what you're thinking and
what you're doing in response to it so
all of my work centers inside this gap
between what's happening in your life
and in your work and what your reaction
is to it and how you can't control
the things that are going on around you
but you can always control what your
reaction is and that gap there that's
about five seconds long and you start to
understand that you can change how you
think you can change your habits you can
change how you lead you can pivot and
change even the philosophy of your
company and you can do it through the
decisions that you're making and
managing your reactions you will become
unstoppable so three years three and a
half years ago i got into the speaking
business um because of the popularity of
that tedx talk that i gave
and um that first year i did um i don't
know i think was like 27 speeches the
next year
i did 87 last year i did 121 i was the
most female speaker in the world this
year i've kept it at 80 and here's why i
realized just like you may be realizing
in your business whatever your business
is that there are aspects of your
business that you love and that energize
you and there are aspects of your
business that are depleting as hell and
that are old and that are tired and that
if you continue in that lane you're
going to end up 10 years from now in a
place that you don't want to be
it's so important for you to pay
attention to what's energizing you about
the landscape around you and about your
own business because that's the secret
to seeing around corners and so the
corner that i was seeing around is that
as an entrepreneur even though it's
wildly lucrative to do what i do just on
the speaking platform i mean anybody can
do the math on 121 speeches right and
the amount of money that i get paid to
show up and deliver a one-hour talk and
realize there's a lot of money here's
the problem it's a terrible business
because you can't scale it other than
raising your price or raising the number
of times you do it and guess what else
you have to show up
and i can't sell it
so i found myself in a situation where i
had built a
multi-million dollar business
highly
profitable
and it was depleting the hell out of me
and i can't really scale it and i can't
sell it
terrible op position to be in in an
entrepreneur so i made a decision
that i you know what was it bo that
actually energizes me about my business
and i answered it with the first
question it's hearing from people
i would rather
answer comments on instagram all day
long than stand in a stadium with five
thousand people in it
i get more from the one to one
connection that's what fuels me and so i
had this light bulb moment paying
attention being clear
that wait a minute i don't want to build
the biggest speaking platform and i
don't want to build a coaching business
i want to build a content company i want
to go back to my roots and build a media
company and so with that insight i now
have to change right because the kind of
business woman that runs a multi
multi-million dollar
speaking business where it's just you
and your speaking management firm and
your travel folks and your logistics
people and maybe your social media
manager that's who's on the team the
kind of leader that runs that kind of
team is very different than the kind of
leader that is going to grow a hundred
million dollar media company that's
going to syndicate content every single
day that is going to own what she's
doing that's going to build instagram
and facebook and youtube and linkedin as
my personal abc cnbc fox and this is
what i want you to understand about the
story and that is this in order to get
to the next level in your business you
got to decide right now what habits do
you have as a leader that you have to
change now
because you will not see around the
corner you will not engineer that next
quantum leap unless you personally
change and so one of the reasons why
i've gone from being the most successful
female you know book speaker on the
speaking circuit to launching the number
one book on all of the self-publishing
platform for amazon
and one of the most read books in the
world and
selling like gangbusters still is
because i am constantly innovating
myself
i know that i am the single
biggest problem in my company
and if i don't constantly pivot and
evolve how i lead and what i'm focused
on i'm gonna be the blockade and so
you know stop looking at what everybody
else is doing stop micromanaging the
team and ask yourself
two years from now when you think about
where you want your company to be
what habit do you have to change right
now you think it's a fear of being
uncomfortable or failure that's really
like the barrier for people the barrier
is everybody gives
what other people are thinking yeah
and so they're on camera or they're on a
microphone trying to be smart
or
concerned about whether or not they look
good in the shot
concerned about uh how they sound
whether or not they started if their
neck is turning red like whatever it may
be
and they're so up here that they're not
actually being true to just saying
what's right here absolutely whether
you're speaking from the heart speaking
from the gut like that is the skill to
develop is the ability to be more like
an 11 year old that gets on camera and
can just be themselves instead of being
a 49 year old person censoring
themselves
and that's what i'm talking about when i
talk about the truth when i talk about
authenticity that
people really want to feel that
connection and the only way that they're
going to feel that connection is if you
do the work to remove the own veneer and
the own barriers that you put in between
you and other people
and the number one thing is everybody
gives too much
about what everybody else thinks
and you know who they think the mo
they're worried the most about their
friends
if i put this thing up not for my
friends but for the people that i'm
trying to build a rapport with online my
friends are going to judge me your
friends
seriously if you're out to make a
difference if you're out to share
something that is important to you if
your friends don't like it or don't
support you they're really not your
friends the only step that really works
is action
because if you're stopping to think
about
what people are thinking or whether or
not you're worried about what people are
thinking
you've already fallen into the trap
the second that you push yourself to get
started
through the action itself you are
proving to yourself that even though you
care what everybody thinks you're gonna
do it anyway a big mistake that we make
as entrepreneurs is we think that we've
got to build everything ourselves and
what's super cool about business today
is that there are channels where you can
make money so that you don't have to do
things that are outside your core
expertise you're a photographer you're
amazing at it you're a networker i can
already tell you're amazing at it what
you should never ever do is spend time
building a stock photography
site because that is not your core
capability but if you just focus on
taking photos which you love
and you upload the stuff that you're not
going to monetize some other way to a
stock photography site as long as it's
not other you know it's not as long as
you know you've got the rights to it and
everything else
you can make money on that stuff all day
long and in fact because
so many people are creating content the
stock photography sites have exploded
it's not just getty and stock list and
some of the other ones that a ton of
people use there are there are tons of
them out there and so that's one thing
that you should be doing okay where else
do you want to grow your business i want
to make sure i'm able to do that first
step very well before i progress on to
the to the next phase okay uh i don't
want to do so many different things that
i'm not doing each one of them very well
that's right so anything where you're
going to have to learn a new skill and
somebody else has done it and you can
outsource it just like uploading to
stock sites
that is you don't want to make the
mistake of having your attention go off
the ball which is creating a big library
of photos and building something that
you have no interest in building a year
ago february 28th i believe it was we
launched the five-second rule book and
there are so many lessons in not only
the launch of that book and how i did it
as a business woman but also the
trajectory that has happened since then
number one it's important for you to
know that um
it was one of the top five most read
books on amazon last year it was the
number one audiobook in the world it is
the number one selling title on amazon
and audible self-publishing audible
platform that's really cool because as
an entrepreneur for me personally
it's so important for me to kind to have
control of the work that i'm doing that
decision to self-publish has paid off
more
than it's paid off financially and it
certainly will pay you more in the long
tail financially when you own your work
and when you self-publish and if you
have an idea that you have been thinking
about and you're watching beau's show
and you're watching evan's channel to
get the motivation to continue to tell
your story to do the work to get your
stuff out there the one thing i'll say
is if you believe in what you're doing
don't sell it to somebody
self-publish it because
you will eventually it might not happen
in the first year but eventually your
work will bump into the right audience
and it will grow and it will grow and
you will really regret
having sold for pennies on the dollar
the thing that was really your life's
work and so please please please if
you're
a content generator if you're an
entrepreneur if you're a writer if
you're a song producer own what you're
doing at least in the beginning until
you start to understand the industry and
the economics of things
so a couple things so if you're trying
to stop yourself from repeating a
pattern of behavior let's use drinking
okay um
if you're trying to use it to stop
yourself from drinking
and you feel
yourself being drawn to go pour the
glass of wine because it's six o'clock
right
and you got home and it's time to have
that glass of wine and by the way time
of day is a huge trigger for behaviors
huge trigger so you feel yourself being
drawn toward the glass of wine go five
four three two one and physically move
away from it
so that's one thing that you can do in
terms of the thoughts and we go into
this in depth in the five-second rule
book there's some science around
something called
if-then planning so if then planning
will make you 60 percent more likely to
stick to a commitment and what if then
planning is is it is coming up with a
plan b
before the you know what hits the fan
and so in the case of thinking patterns
that are negative or behavior patterns
like pleasing people or silencing
yourself what i want you to do is it can
be very effective to write down all the
times where you're typically triggered
to do that or to think that negative
thing
then come up with what you're going to
do instead ahead of time
if this person uses that tone of voice
with me and speaks in a different
disrespectful way instead of standing
here and taking it
five four three two one then i'm gonna
do this i am a productivity consultant
i've had a challenge with people
they know what they need to do and this
is my challenge as well i know what i
need to do i know it needs to be done
right getting that motivation and
getting over that ledge and that five
second rule my goodness changed my life
i haven't quite made it to not hitting
snooze yet okay
why
oh because my bed feels so comfy in the
morning let me tell you something okay
are you ready i'm ready
your business will go to the next level
the second
you actually beat the habit of hitting
the snooze
and the reason why
is because of the science around
productivity and the brain okay and when
you push yourself
to walk the talk and have the first 30
minutes of your day
be the most productive for your brain
you will bring a level of conviction
and authority and impact
to the business that's not there
currently right
you see when you're uh an expert and
you're a consultant
your power is limited
to the extent that you personally feel
like you're not using the tools does
that make sense
i say this for myself
i say this because
when i think
about
businesses that i've had in the past or
when i was an executive coach and i
would be giving advice but i'm not
technically following it in the same
regard i'm not as powerful right and so
i would highly highly highly
encourage you
starting tomorrow morning you want to be
the best productivity coach on the
planet that alarm goes off notice the
gap right because the more that you
start to play with this five second
window and you go five four three two
one and you push yourself out of bed and
you hate it and then you take your cold
shower and you hate it and then you
don't look at your phone and you hate it
and then you spend the first 30 minutes
of the day pushing something forward and
you hate it but you do it
you will now be able to coach people who
do the exact same thing
understand
that
you can find people to support you
you will always find people to criticize
you watch though how when somebody
outside of you criticizes you
how that triggers the internal pattern
so what is the pattern that you have of
thinking
that gets triggered that disempowers you
that i won't have any words you won't
have any words let's go deeper than that
is it something about being loved or
being unworthy or not being good enough
what is underneath i won't have the
words yeah they won't be the right words
and i it won't be good enough yeah okay
and so do you have an opinion that
you're not good enough or not deserving
of success
or that you're not
smart enough to make a difference
yeah what is the one what is what is the
thing that hooks you
that you say to yourself
that i'm stupid that they're okay there
we go that's a good one not a good one
but you know what i mean that's a good
one because
that's my baby okay i'm a piece of
[Music]
now we're talking yeah that's the big
one who told you that i don't i don't
know who told me that when did you start
believing that
it's a little girl yeah
god i've just been saying it for so long
i i don't know
that's okay she said i've been saying it
for so long i don't know
as you now know what you're looking for
you're going to start to connect the
dots okay and so here's the thing
at some point
you started telling yourself whatever
i'm a piece as a strategy you did it on
purpose as a youngster
as a way to survive things that were
happening because maybe when you said
well i'm a piece of you actually got
really quiet and you didn't get hit
or maybe when you said that you uh
removed yourself from situations
when you would have been abused or
something it worked because it protected
you as weird as it sounds yeah is that
are you seeing something what are you
seeing
well yeah my dad didn't want he wanted
me to be quiet in the corner being quiet
yeah he couldn't
make noise and okay
and if you got if you raised your voice
you got in trouble
so do you guys see the link now between
why she has a concern about finding her
words
oh yeah i didn't get that one you see
that now yeah so
every time that you are in a situation
where you need to speak up how many are
you relating to this by the way
i have a theory about all of us
that we have
patterns and strategies that we we
created when we were little
in order to survive situations
and what she internalized was don't
speak up
and you're a piece of if you do
and
believe me that protected your ass it
worked because you didn't speak up and
you didn't get in trouble with your dad
right and i still got the love so if i
speak up now i'm going to lose my dad's
love do you see this
so this is a pattern that got
written when she was little
and it was written by someone else and
it worked it worked
the problem is now that you're working
now it's not working now
it's not working now not working now and
see
exactly and so this is what's
fascinating about all this there are
places in your life where you have
patterns that you don't even recognize
that were strategies that you developed
when you were a kid and so in the areas
where you're really frustrated that
pattern is probably
not
present or conscious
something that you're aware of
and so every single time because you've
been repeating this and repeating it and
repeating it every single time you're
about to hit play every single time
you're going to stand on a stage what's
going to be right there is don't speak
up
you're yes freeze and you're gonna go
five four three two one the only thing
to
that actually overrides this pattern is
to speak
and through speaking
you will see that you're not a piece of
[ __ ]
you actually have something to say
or you could make fun of it and say well
i guess i'm just a piece of something to
say
that's right and i also like the
strategy of kind of making the fun of
the stuff
even the heavy stuff
because it loses its grip on me it works
for me it may not work for you
but it's something to try you're never
ever ever ever going to feel like doing
the things you need to do
in order to have what you want
you're always going to need to push
yourself you're always going to need to
parent yourself
so what is the net advice on this what
what is the bottom line
the bottom line is no one's coming
no one
no one's coming to push you
no one's coming to tell you to turn the
tv off
no one's coming to tell you to get out
the door and exercise nobody's coming to
tell you to apply for that job that
you've always dreamt about nobody's
coming to write the business plan for
you it's up to you
and because you're only ever going to do
the things that you feel like doing
right now or that feel good right now
unless you understand
that you've got to parent yourself you
got to push yourself
you're not going to make your dreams
come true you're just not
we're not wired that way you weren't
born that way you weren't that way when
you were growing up and you're certainly
not that way as an adult and there's a
tremendous amount of liberation that
comes when you accept the fact that
you're always going to need to give
yourself a push well i want to talk to
those of you that are working toward
your dreams
whatever it is that you're doing right
now it's leading to
the thing that you dream of doing and
you're not going to progress until you
get the skills and the experience that
you need at the level that you're at i
guarantee you even if you're working at
a
front desk
job at a local gym you're learning
customer service you need to learn that
kind of stuff before you can launch your
own business for me in order to be an
incredible speaker that can command a
stage with 3 000 people in the audience
for an entire hour i first had to learn
how to have the courage to speak up and
have hard conversations in my life then
i had to learn how to speak up in a
small meeting then i had to learn how to
speak up
you know in a church basement then i had
to learn how to give a little bit of a
talk at a brown bag luncheon then i had
to learn how to stand on a slightly
bigger stage so if you're frustrated
with where you are right now because
you've got these big dreams and you
think you're really far away
here's one way that you can continue to
be patient and you can milk wherever
you're at to help you build the skills
and the experience that you need as you
climb toward the thing that you want
ask yourself what is it that i am
learning what's the skill that i'm
honing by sitting here at this front
desk job or driving this uber or lyft
vehicle what am i learning that i'm
going to take with me on my journey to
do that next big thing because i
guarantee you there's something in the
minutia of what you're doing right now
that you are developing an expertise and
a skill around that you're gonna need as
you launch yourself towards the next
thing okay great so here's what you're
gonna do it's actually simple but it's
not going to be easy because you're
going to create all kinds of excuses and
drama for yourself okay you're going to
set your alarm perception and when the
alarm goes off that's what happened that
gap is going to open up and you're going
to feel all roll it i don't feel like it
i'm
over i don't want to i don't feel like
writing a song anyway you know like
that's when you have to take control you
have to take control you have to get up
every morning it begins by getting up
because if you let anxiety excuses
self-doubt all the
win in that first decision the rest of
the day is hijacked so win the first
decision then exercise i don't care
about the eating as much i know it's
important not to put garbage in but i
would rather see you first master
getting up on time do that for a week
then let's add in exercise every day 10
minutes don't start with like two hours
because then you're gonna find an excuse
not to do it get up at seven exercise
for ten minutes then the third week
you're gonna add in like i'm actually
gonna eat clean this week or whatever
the diet is that you wanna eat right
you're just gonna add in things as you
master the little things but you've got
to get up on time it starts right there
okay you know we all face problems in
our lives it's just part of being a
human being but have you ever considered
that there are really only two kinds of
problems that you're ever going to face
there are temporary problems and then
there are permanent problems that are
more like conditions that you have to
learn with now a temporary problem is
something that you have tremendous power
to change and permanent problems though
are
something that require a different skill
and that is the ability to just accept
things as they are
and let the complaining go now one of
the skills in life that is really going
to help you become a great problem
solver and it's also going to give you
more control over your life is knowing
what kind of problem you're actually
dealing with because we all complain
about our problems but to actually solve
a problem you got to understand what
kind of problem you're dealing with the
truth is you can't change a permanent
problem so no matter how much you
complain about it how much you try to
change it how much energy you put into
it nothing's changing it's a waste of
your time and your energy to focus on
those now when you try to change a
permanent problem you know you are stuck
because you feel like you're just
spinning in circles temporary problems
are what you want to focus your energy
on these are the decisions and the life
choices that you keep making
that might feel good in the moment but
they actually make you miserable now
here's the thing about temporary
problems they're not permanent you may
hate your body but you can change it
you may hate and be unhappy in the
relationship that you're in but you can
change it
you might complain a lot about how your
boss treats you or how you feel passed
over at work but you can change how you
interact with your boss and you can
change how you show up at work and you
can even change your job that's the
difference between a temporary and a
permanent problem temporary problems you
can change now here's a simple exercise
that i want you to do i want you to make
a list of all the things that you
complain about
maybe you complain about your commute
where you live the person you're with
your health your boss the amount of
money you have now i want you to look at
every single complaint you have and ask
yourself what can i do
to change this problem what can i do to
fix my relationship with your boss
because you can't change your boss's
personality but you can definitely
change how you interact with her
and when you change yourself and your
own behaviors and how you think
you're gonna change everything i've
always been very scared
and
lack of confidence and thought that i
was never good enough like some of my
partners we've all bought into a lie
we've bought into a lie that confidence
is belief in self and so when you're in
a situation which is normal where you
don't believe in yourself you're like oh
my god i have no confidence the truth is
and i want you to walk out of here with
a new definition of confidence
confidence is the willingness to try
because when you try and you take action
what happens and what's happened for
france is that
when she sees herself taking action
what happens is she sees herself being
the kind of person that takes action so
she has evidence
that she can rely on herself and that
action is what builds confidence it
doesn't start with belief the real way
the real way for most of us is not to
wait to believe but to push ourselves to
act and through the action you will
build the belief let's pretend that this
right here this empty mason jar is your
brain in order to do your best thinking
you need to make sure that you've got
the full capacity of your brain
leveraged and pointed at the things that
are important to you here's the problem
when you go through life as you go
through life what happens is you know
your brain starts to fill up with
information and that's what creates a
state of feeling overwhelmed being
overwhelmed is nothing more than having
a full brain so as you go through your
day-to-day life and you start checking
email and looking at texts and looking
at facebook and sitting in meetings and
flipping through television channels and
sending emails and writing excel
spreadsheets and
running and picking up the kids at work
and getting another text and looking at
instagram and looking at twitter and
checking out the news
your brain gets pretty full doesn't it
and so when you feel overwhelmed what i
know about you is that your brain is
full of a bunch of garbage
and so oh i didn't think about the drain
draining i hope that's not bothering you
but it's certainly going to bother me
what you need to do in order to fight
overwhelm is you've got to actually do a
brain dump
you got to get rid of all that stuff so
that you've got an empty brain so you
can focus again so how do you do that
it's easy to do with a cup of water
because you just pour it out this is
what you're going to do you are
literally going to dump out everything
that's in your head onto this piece of
paper every concern every worry every
to-do every thing that's bothering you
that you're thinking about you're gonna
write down
[Music]
all right and when you're done writing
down everything that's in your head and
there's absolutely nothing left oh
i've got something due tomorrow that i
kind of forgot about um once you get
that stuff all done on a piece of paper
pull out a highlighter take a look
you could do everything on this list you
could
but what should you do what are three
things just three that you should do
in order to advance the things that
matter to you
let's see i gotta do that one
i gotta do that one and i gotta do that
one
the rest of this list
is complete and other garbage it's other
people's stuff it's the email stuff it's
the meeting stuff it's the stuff that's
not all that important to me it's not
that mission critical so by dumping
everything out
i now not only have the three things i
need to do
i've got a clear head so i can get it
done if you're about to do something for
the first time chances are high that you
might embarrass yourself but what it
means is if you're willing to be the
kind of person that is willing to
embarrass themselves it means you're
trying something new it means you're
going for it when everybody else sits on
the sidelines and so one of the things
that i would encourage you to do is that
when you feel that tingling like you're
starting to hold yourself back because
you start thinking about what all your
friends are thinking about that's a
moment to go oh this is what that lady
was talking about five four three two
one i'm going for it the thing that's
that that you guys also need to know is
that i know that we parents
harp on you in terms of how important
your friends are and we always say oh
well don't who cares what your friends
think the research shows that actually
between now and the age of 25 your
friends are the most important thing in
your life in terms of defining who you
are and that also means that right now
in your life the fear of embarrassment
because you're trying to fit in you're
trying to find your squad it's going to
be bigger than ever so if you can become
the kind of person that's like all right
here's the moment oh i'm about to
embarrass myself 54321 i'm going what
you're going to find is your friends are
going to start doing the same thing and
they're going to start to cheer for you
because you're the one that they can
count on to break the ice you're the one
that they can count on to go first
you're the one that they can count on to
put his ideas out there and it's like
one of the coolest things that you could
develop you're not a procrastinator
you have a habit
of procrastinating
big difference
because if it's a habit
i can teach you to use science to break
it
you see all habits have three parts
there's a trigger and in the case of
procrastination the trigger is always
stress
then there's a pattern you repeat and in
the case of procrastination it is to
avoid doing something and then there's a
reward you get a little stress relief
the only way to break a habit you guys
is not to deal with the triggers
you're never going to get rid of the
stress in your life but you can 100
change your pattern of avoiding work
so next time that you're in a situation
where you feel yourself hesitate you
spent way too much time checking out the
highlights from last night's scores what
you're going to do is you're going to go
oh i must be stressed out about
something acknowledge the stress then go
five four three two one i want you to
count to yourself because i want you to
interrupt the habit that's stored here
and i want you to awaken your prefrontal
cortex then i want you to just work just
for five minutes the reason why i want
you to only work for five minutes is
because your problem isn't working
it's the habit of avoiding
i just need you to start and here's the
other cool thing
we know based on research that if we can
get you to start 80 percent of you are
going to keep going if your friend is
facing a problem when you have to make
decisions on behalf of your friend you
tend to
think from multiple perspectives you
think about multiple outcomes and
ultimately you make a much better
decision what they found in research
though is if they put you in the exact
same situation facing the exact same
thing that your friend is you're not
able to be so objective because you're
emotional and you don't make that great
a decision what's the conclusion well
when you make decisions for other people
you're great when we make decisions for
ourselves decisions that can be
emotional we're not so good at it that's
where the power of objectivity comes in
it's the ability to make a decision from
a third party's perspective let me
explain so if you're facing a really
important decision and you can feel
yourself getting emotional maybe you're
thinking about asking for a raise or
changing your career or changing your
major or ending a relationship or
starting a relationship whatever it may
be if it's something that is emotional
for you
you're going to have a hard time
thinking about all the options and
you're going to be really attached
emotionally because maybe you're
concerned about the people who may be
impacted by your decision maybe you're
managing that somebody's going to be
disappointed or hurt by what you need to
do for you this is when the power of
objectivity is really important pick
somebody that you really admire i mean
it could be somebody like a bill gates
or richard branson or an oprah winfrey
or maybe have a mentor and stop yourself
and ask what would oprah do in this
situation what would richard branson do
in this situation what would your mentor
do in this situation
bringing that level of third-party
objectivity will yank you
out of your body and your emotions and
it will help you give yourself the
perspective that you need and the
distance from your emotions so that you
can actually assess your options and
make the best decision for you
what would mel do if mel were making the
decision the best decision you know
there's a really interesting example of
somebody who did this in sports and at
the time he actually got a lot of flack
for it it was lebron james now lebron
james as you know played for the
cleveland cavaliers for a really really
long time and he's arguably one of the
best basketball players to ever hit the
nba so he made this announcement that he
was going to leave the cleveland
cavaliers where he had been playing
forever had rabid rabid fans and he was
going to leave them and go to miami
miami heat
that was the conclusion you woke up with
this morning that was the conclusion i
woke up with this morning
he was giving an interview to espn and
what he said was this he said lebron
james needs to do what's best for lebron
james
now people kind of laughed at him
because it's a funny way to say the
sentence but this guy's really smart he
was leveraging the power of objectivity
mel robbins needs to learn how to do
what's best for mel robbins and you need
to learn how to do what's best for you
the thing that i'm stuck on is that i
have a bazillion ideas about things that
i can create and do and courses and
trainings and la di da da who can relate
and so actually moving from the idea and
even creating the whole
curriculum and all of that to actually
making it happen yeah and doing it so i
have a cool strategy that i use and i
hope it works for you so i carry
a little notebook and i actually
borrowed this from chris because when we
lived in new york city he used to carry
around a notebook like this size and
whenever he had an idea he'd just jot it
down then he'd stick it in his back
pocket and he was just full of all kinds
of stuff so i carry around a notebook
and this one's new so it doesn't really
have much in it as ideas come i just jot
it down in that notebook and then what
happens for me
is i get anxiety
because i'm afraid that i'm going to
forget the idea
then that anxiety makes me get
distracted and
unfocused and overwhelmed and so i think
if you were to have a little notebook on
you at all times and when those creative
juices and those impulses go that you
jot them down
that's gonna remove one layer of the
overwhelm if you have friends
that make you wrong for changing your
life for the better that's their issue
it's not yours and so you gotta untangle
the fact that they have baggage about
getting in shape or they have baggage
about going to the bar that's theirs and
it has nothing to do with the decisions
that you're making so if your friends in
general give you blowback for changing
for the better what you need to say in
the back of your mind is interesting
they're obviously very conflicted about
their choice to go to the bar and drink
every night but that has nothing to do
with me here's the other thing you can
do if they start to make you wrong you
can say well you want to go to planet
fitness with me instead it doesn't sound
like you want to be at the bar so that
said let me talk to you a little bit
about friends friends are people that
you care about and i have this test i
call it the funeral test if somebody in
your life were to die ask yourself would
i go to their funeral if the answer is
yes they're a friend of yours that's the
test for whether or not in my opinion
someone is a friend because it means you
care about them now here's the other
thing about friendship that i want you
to understand you can care about
somebody and not like hanging out with
them and that's the situation that
you're in right now that you have plenty
of friends that you care about if they
were to die you would go to their
funeral if they needed you you would be
there if you saw them you'd be happy to
see them but you don't like to hang out
with them the other thing that i want
you to think about is that and that's
okay that's like a normal part of
friendship and the reason why that's a
normal part of friendship is because one
of the things that we know about life is
that you're always going to be changing
in the old pattern and the old chapter
you had certain patterns right in the
old chapter of your life you would go to
the bar and drink you would go to the
store and spend money you didn't have
you're in a new chapter now and so you
have different patterns when your life
takes on different patterns whether it's
you're no longer going to the bar you're
going to the gym the pattern might even
be that one of your kids is playing with
a different soccer team or maybe you've
moved to a different street in your town
when the patterns change so will your
circle of friends it's a fact of life
but that doesn't mean your old friends
the ones that you used to drink with
aren't friends anymore it just means
that you don't want to hang out with
them you still care about them but you
don't like doing what they do the
patterns have changed for a long time i
had a lot of drama around this until i
realized that it's not personal it's not
personal that you don't want to hang out
with them patterns in your life have
simply changed the final thing that i
want to leave you with that may also
help you is that remember i've given you
the funeral test if you'd go to their
funeral they're definitely a friend it
means you care about them but you might
not like hanging out with them that much
and that's cool that's normal the other
thing that i want you to think about
when it comes to friendships is you can
typically put friends into three buckets
you got friends for a reason you got
friends for a season and you have
friends for a lifetime and one of the
interesting things that i know about my
own life is that as the patterns of my
life change so do the friends that i
hang out with more frequently and i also
believe that as you change and the
patterns in your life change people show
up in your life for a reason the right
people will show up when you start going
to the gym the right people that you
need for the pattern that you're in
right now will start showing up when
you're working on your project instead
of shopping and it's exactly the kind of
people that you need they're there for a
reason and the friends of yours that are
friends of yours for a lifetime i bet
you don't hang out with them that much
at all anyway but i bet they're the
first person that you call when you need
to talk to somebody about somebody
important those are the friends for a
lifetime and those folks that are still
sitting at the bar and love to blow
money that they don't have those were
friends for a season it turns out that
one of the best stress relievers on the
planet is something that most of us
don't ever do and that is
seek out time with friends when we feel
totally stressed out when you're doing
twice as much work as you normally do or
you're feeling twice as much stress as
you normally feel
studies at harvard show that what you
need is you need to see your friends
twice as much
now sean anker is a really famous
researcher and best-selling author at
harvard and he studied this phenomenon
he looked at at people that were
stressed at schools and in call centers
and in the military and in banks and in
almost every single industry what he
discovered is that the most successful
people the people that were the best at
selling the people that they were the
most resilient the people that had the
best ability to deal with stress when
times got tough were the ones that saw
their friends the most it was the people
with the tightest social connections
that had the ability to weather the
storms that life throw at us i want you
to write down three people
three people that when you hang out with
them you feel energized that when you
have plans with them you're excited
about seeing them
when this video ends reach out to them
that's right pick up the phone send them
a text i want you to invite them to do
something go out to lunch go for a walk
in the woods get a cup of coffee go out
to dinner even if you're not stressed
out i guarantee you at least one of the
three people that you're going to reach
out to needs you
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
recent interview with mel robbins
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i hope your business goes bankrupt
evan evan you're a terrible person i
spent the first
40-some years of my life trying to be
somebody else i'll give you guys a
secret way